(laughing)
- [Announcer] Good morning
ladies and gentlemen.
Please welcome to the
stage Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
Welcome to VoiceCon.
I'm extremely excited about this.
When I think about what the
team has done to get us here
I'm just very proud and so
obviously when VaynerMedia
and VaynerX in general decided
to start putting on events
in 2018 we thought a lot about the IP
or the places we wanted to play.
And so before I go into
this I just wanna give
a huge shout out to Kim and
Emma and the rest of the
VaynerExperience team
and everybody at Vayner.
I'd love for you to clap it up for them.
(audience applauding)
One of the things that's interesting about
having an event be your event
versus what I normally do
which is fly in and
speak and give a keynote,
is being a host is definitely
different than being a guest
or a special guest and so
I gave a lot of thought to
the rest of the line up.
As this was being built
out I was just overwhelmed
and impressed with who we
were able to get lined up
for this event and so to
try to reverse engineer
why you're here and think about
the value that I can bring
in the line up, I think that
respecting your audience
is always the most important
part to create success.
As a matter of fact, probably
as a quick side note,
the most interesting thing for
me in the voice space is that
we have not established
kind of the UI and the UX
and the interface of
how we're gonna interact
with these things as they become
dramatically more sophisticated.
That comes along with empathy
and respect for the end user.
You being at this conference all day
the empathy and respect
I have for you is that
we have a very detailed curriculum
and line up at this event
where I think a lot of
people are gonna nerd it out
and so I'm not gonna nerd it out.
I'm gonna go on a little bit
of a different direction.
I wanna set up the framework
of why this event even exists
and why, for many of you if you follow me
in any shape or form, are
hearing me pontificate
and push and propaganda this space.
It comes down to, it was interesting,
Matt Guerin, who's gonna
do a great job after me
here from Vayner, asked me literally,
or Kim just asked me, Matt
just asked me actually,
he said what are you gonna talk about.
I looked at him like I
have no fucking idea.
And it was really interesting
because the reality is
I don't but I do and I do
because of the following.
In my career at this point, in my life,
it's been interesting to
watch pattern recognition.
As I was sitting back there
getting ready for this talk
the only feeling and kind of
thought and vibe that I had
was very similar to the vibe I had
the first time I was sitting in front of
seven liquor store owners.
My dad's liquor store was part of a co-op
where there were other owners
and they all kind of owned
Shoppers Discount Liquors.
They were independent but they were buying
an advertising co-op and I
remember going to a meeting
in 1996 where I was going to let them know
that I was starting a website.
And we're in this meeting
and I'm like yeah,
we're gonna launch this
thing and we're gonna call it
winelibrary.com, which
was already a little weird
'cause we were Shoppers Discount Liquors.
And I just remember the enormous scrutiny
and almost disrespect
through everybody's faces
because basically what the
energy of that room told me
is that nobody's gonna buy
wine from this internet thing.
I genuinely believed that
more than half that room
had no idea what the internet was, right.
And so when I sit here today,
this is a pretty fancy event,
meaning not only are the
speakers pretty educated
and far along with technology and business
but so is the audience itself.
I've been thinking a lot, I'm like huh,
it's really quite interesting
that nobody in this room,
including myself,
actually fully understands
how deep this is gonna go and
here's what I mean by that.
I think it's very hard for us
in this room, at this moment,
at this apex of text messaging
and mobile addiction,
I think it's hard for us to understand
that there's a high
likelihood that in 10 years,
that so many of you are
gonna give up on texting
for voice AI devices.
It's just hard to make the leap that
what you've now become completely
foundationally living on
as your execution of
communication, as a platform,
is going to be disrupted.
No different, it's funny, I
love when young becomes old.
I love that there's so many
people in here that I know
and so many of my friends that are now
in their 30s, 40s, 50s, who
were such thought leaders
20 years ago, 25 years ago,
about digital and social
and the internet itself,
who now are gonna struggle
with this transition.
Who don't think they're
gonna stop texting.
In the same way that
they made fun of people
who didn't think they were
gonna text a decade ago.
And so I think, for everybody here,
I think there's a lot
of entrepreneurs here
and a lot of Fortune 500's here
and I think the theme for me is
you're about to hear a
lot of incredible data.
Depending on the study you look at
when you look at 50 to 100
million devices in home already,
AI voice devices in the marketplace,
when you think about how
many more that's going to be
in the 12 to 24 months
but more importantly,
for the people that are advanced
in their technology thinking,
when you know in a half
decade it's not even gonna be
those devices and it's
gonna be integrated into
every single product in our lives.
Including, when your shower
head is voice activated
and you remember something
that you need to do
and you just tell somebody
you're gonna be 10 minutes late
or what's my meeting tonight at seven.
I don't think that we have quantified
our unbelievable addiction for speed.
Everything that happens,
pretty much, I'm a simple guy.
I talk a lot about day trading attention.
A lot of it is just
predicating the fact that
you guys hate friction.
That we as a society give
up everything, privacy.
We will give up privacy all
day to win back three minutes.
We just love speed.
We subconsciously understand the time.
You hear that saying time is, right.
We subconsciously, deeply understand that.
To me it was really fascinating early on
to see Uber succeed, watching
Travis navigate that business
and later as an early investor.
What struck me so early on is like
these people can't afford it.
I was looking at some
of the data and I'm like
they can't afford it.
Why are they taking these $28,
right, they can't afford it.
And what you just start realizing is
convenience is king.
I grew up in retail.
Convenience is king is super-duper real.
There is nothing more convenient
than voice infrastructure
around us, period.
This space is going to
win and it's going to win
in a big game and in a big way.
This space is also
unbelievably fascinating
because it is not visual.
Let me explain to you why this matters.
I'm gonna paint you a scenario.
When you think about
the search engine wars
of the early 2000s, even
when Google won and became
a real dominant force and they
started having an ad product
and people started
freaking out how powerful
search engines were, when
somebody would type in Coca-Cola
and Pepsi had the ability to have an ad.
Even to this day, in the small
screen of a mobile device,
even when somebody buys your category
or your brand as an ad, you're
still showing up organically
in the UI of the visual and
if I'm typing in Reebok,
even though there may be a Nike ad,
if my intent was Reebok
and even though I might be
seduced for a second by that Nike ad,
my intent going in was still that
and I have the ability to buy that.
What's fascinating to me is
we do not have that luxury in voice.
What's fascinating to me about voice is
the players that win this
game, Amazon, Google, Apple.
Facebook, I assume, has to
be doing something secretly
in some fucking secret warehouse.
(audience laughing)
And anybody else that we can't see,
whether it's a China based
Tencent or somebody else
or something else that is just
two 18 year old girls
right now in Tennessee
who have an idea and are
able to put it together
and get there.
Whoever it's going to be,
they're going to have remarkable,
and I mean remarkable leverage.
To me the internet is the
foundation of our society
and then you've got four
to seven internet companies
that are layers on top of that
and then for everyone of
us here our job is to be
the next layer above that.
These tolbooths, Google,
Amazon, Apple, in voice,
are set to make so much more money
and have so much more power.
It's also why, for the people.
How many people here run
or think they have a brand,
raise your hands.
So this is super important to me.
In the internet age we have
had incredibly fascinating
confusion between selling and branding.
I listen to people everyday
talk about business
and they don't realize that
they're just sales people
but they're talking like
they're marketing or branding.
What they care about is CAC and LTV
and last touch attribution
and really just hacking,
math based marketing,
which I'm a huge fan of.
I just think it's half of the equation.
I think the art and the
creative is the other half
and I've spent the last
decade being fascinated by
Wall Street and Madison Avenue
just being completely
based on subjective art
and bullshit reporting and
then Silicon Valley being
disproportionately addicted to math
and not realizing that
that eventually runs out
and that becomes their vulnerability.
To me the thing that I'm
probably most passionate about
with voice is the fact
that brand has never become
more important.
Every single person here is going to buy
an obnoxious amount of
products, goods and services
on a voice device in a decade.
And I mean most of it.
When that happens you
will start realizing why
things like Kleenex and Xerox and Uber
were the most important players.
If you do not start the process right now
of branding Chips Ahoy over cookies,
what's going to happen
is we're just gonna say
Alexa or Google, send me
some chocolate chip cookies.
And our battle is going to be Alexa,
send me some Chips Ahoy.
Because I promise you, 'cause
Amazon is a fucking gangster.
If you say Chips Ahoy
you've gotta get those
but if you say cookies you're
getting Amazon's private label
and or Mondelez in that scenario
is paying a quadrillion dollars.
I laugh when I meet with my CPG clients.
They're concerned about
the amount of money
that have to pour into trade.
And for the entrepreneurs in this room
that means good end caps
at Walmart when you walk in
and how much they extract.
Or when they're on deal
they have to subsidize
the coupon price.
That's gonna be child's
play compared to being
the default product when somebody asks for
a category product.
When you ask for jeans how
much is Calvin Klein or Levis
gonna have to pay to be that product
verus the margin that Amazon makes
in having their own private
label, versus Google going out
and buying Levis and owning it
and making that the default.
My friends, I think the
Amazon purchase of wholefoods
was a watershed moment that
finally got people to understand
that this is just starting.
That these companies
have a lot of leverage.
When target sells to Amazon
or Facebook or Google
people are gonna start waking
up to what's happening.
And the thing that's
fascinating to me is that voice,
in a lot of ways, has
that parallel impact.
I do not think people understand
how much voice is gonna affect
the entire restaurant industry.
There is no OpenTable or Resy or Yelp.
There's voice.
And the smarts is something I think
a lot of people are gonna struggle with.
How many people here saw
the Google presentation
with the assistant making the reservation,
just raise it high.
What do you think that technology
looks like in seven years?
Right.
I mean this shit is getting
continuously smarter.
The other thing that fascinates me is
the things we think we don't want
versus the things we do want.
I think that most people, when
the propaganda goes against
voice devices listening to you,
people are gonna talk about
that's scary, that's bullshit,
I'm not gonna have one, privacy.
Yet I think nine out of 10 of you
are not actually gonna care about that.
And I think that watching
the counter-arguments
of what's going on is super fascinating
'cause I think we grossly
underestimate how we actually work
and how psychology is actually wired.
I think we are in the early
stages and so, for me,
being laughed at for website in '96
or being completely looked upon.
As I sit here today the
other feeling I have is
the feeling I had in November 2005
when I decided that I was
gonna start a YouTube show
after the holidays for my wine show
and that YouTube literally
did not have a video yet,
there was not a single video on YouTube
that had a million views.
It was a baby.
And I watched my entire 100
person staff at Wine Library
in February of 2006 think
that I lost my complete mind.
That I went from working
hard and doing my thing
and buying and meeting
and tasting and doing this
and now all of a sudden I
was locked up in my office
filming this thing,
trying to get people to
watch the show on YouTube.
And so that, and then
obviously investing very deeply
and probably the biggest parallel for me
about this conference and
the biggest feeling I had
backstage which is the conference that
completely changed my
life was FOWA in 2007.
There was a conference in
February 2007 in London.
It was called FOWA.
Ryan Carson put it on.
It was called the Future of Web Apps.
And I remember, I went to it,
and I remember just sitting there
and listening to the presentations
and I remember thinking
that my life was gonna be
different from here on out.
That I fully understood
that this internet thing
that helped grow my family
business and sell stuff
was just starting.
Obviously when you're impacted
and I would say the
biggest fear I have here.
How many people here feel
that they've been positively,
professionally impacted by
the internet or social media?
Raise your hands.
It's my biggest fear because
that's what happened to me.
In 2007 I'm walking in
and I'd made it, right.
I'd built this business,
I'd made it and I remember,
luckily in that conference I
realized I didn't make shit.
Like this is just starting.
This is not even, forget
about the national anthem
in this game, I haven't
even left the home yet
to get to the parking lot to tailgate.
This is just starting.
And it really switched for me
and made a totally different
commitment to this device
and more importantly
to Twitter and Facebook
which obviously changed
the path of my career.
My big hope today, through
the details of the panels
and the keynotes and through
the Q&A I wanna serve up here
in about 10 minutes,
where we can go detailed
and I'd love to answer any of
your questions of what I see
or what we're seeing or how it's going,
is that this becomes the watershed moment.
The reason I wanted to do VoiceCon is
not since social media 2005, '06
and not since internet '94 '95
had I felt the chemicals in my body
that have dictated my career which is
I know what you're gonna do
before you know you're gonna do it.
And I know that everybody
here is underestimating
how voice is about to change their lives
and how that affects you as a human
and how that affects you personally
and how that affects you professionally
is something that I want
you to really ponder.
Please don't be like a lot of my homies
that came to those social
media conferences with me
in 2006 and '07 and didn't fully see it
and now talk to me 10
years later and regret
not squeezing harder or betting harder
or being in it harder because
they knew it, they saw it
but they were too passive
and or they underestimated
how big it was going to be.
To me, in the same way that
social has clearly changed
not only business but
politics and psychology
of our end user and just
who we are as human beings,
voice is gonna have that same ability.
It's crazy, how many people
here have children under eight.
The education they have around
their interests because of,
I mean it's crazy, like the
knowledge a five year old has
around information that
they're interested in
when they can't read or
write yet, is fascinating.
I mean for everybody who
just raised their hand,
kids know so much about something
that they could've never known
because they would've had to read it.
And now they've got it in
their head at scale, on demand,
always when they need it
and what that's gonna
do for us is remarkable.
You're gonna be meeting.
By the way this is the death of bets.
You know like the random bet,
you get into an argument with your buddy
and you're trying to
figure out who's right.
How many touchdowns they scored
or how many square footages
or what did it.
You're just gonna get the answer.
You'll never believe how lazy we are.
That's what I thought the
mobile device was gonna do
but you still don't wanna
grab it and Google it.
You'd rather literally fucking
debate it for another hour.
(audience laughing)
'Cause it is fun and
we'll always keep those
human elements but man I'm
gonna tell you something.
The passive nature, the ambience of voice,
the complete zero friction.
This is still friction.
As crazy as it sounds grabbing
it and doing something
is still friction.
This is not.
And so for me this conference
is unbelievably selfish.
I'm being very frank.
This is an unbelievably selfish conference
because I'm very excited
that our company gets to put
a flag in the ground in this space.
I believe that so many of
you are on the verge of
disproportionately impacting your business
because of this space.
And I think that there's a lot of things
we need to think about.
How many people here own or
are a very senior executive
of a business?
Great.
I bet you that you've never thought about
what your business sounds like.
Like sitting here and realizing oh shit,
I'm gonna have to have a
conversation with my dad Sasha
about what's the voice of
Wine Library sound like,
is a pretty exciting kind of conversation,
just out of humor for me as a human.
But I think it's very
important, especially.
It's just something we don't think about.
It's something that we
could've never thought about.
In the same way that we could
have never thought about
how important a logo was for social
or things of that nature or your tagline
and things of that nature,
how unbelievably important
over the next decade or two,
what your brand sounds like
is actually going to be
a variable of success.
Is it a male voice, is it a
female voice, is it a mix?
What's the slang?
The sound of your brand.
Something none of us
could've ever saw coming.
So the other thing I
wanna touch on is that
there's a lot of people in
here who have an advantage
that voice is about to collapse.
For example, I think the
biggest stakes being played out
right now with voice are for Google.
Google makes a lot of money on search.
A lot.
I think that search is on call right now
because of the voice space.
Obviously will continue to do visual,
obviously you'll be on a
plane and other places,
but I think the amount of search
because a lot of the percentage of search
is search to action.
And the fact that voice
can do that passively.
Guys, I'm bouncing here
a little bit but just
voice to action.
The thing that I'm most
excited about for voice
is the fact that my calendar's
gonna be hooked up to it
and so are all the other
busy people that I know
and instead of going through
and wasting 28 minutes
or five hours of my admin and my own time
to try to schedule an important
meeting over and over,
if I just say I wanna have a meeting with
X, Y, Z person and the
fact that the device
is gonna be able to look at
my calendar and that calendar
and actually tell both
of us at that moment
that actually, even though
that you're both executives
in New York, the prime time
for you guys to actually meet
is in Houston between one and three
because you both have
downtime, is just remarkable.
And just a simple little execution of
what's going to save us time.
But technology has always saved us time
and made us more efficient.
I was telling my buddy the other day,
I was having a conversation, it was wild.
How many people here
are over the age of 35?
Raise your hands.
Perfect.
So youngsters you gotta hear this.
Back when we were kids
(audience laughing)
if you wanted to meet your
friend somewhere in public
it went down like this.
You'd have to tell them in school that day
that you were meeting at
4:15 and you had to meet by
the big water fountain
at the fucking mall.
But here's where it gets gnarly.
If, for some weird reason,
your mom was running late
and you got there at 4:25
there was a 50 50 chance
that the person gave up
and you never saw them.
It's just remarkable how, in
a very short period of time,
that seems ludicrous because of this
and the biggest framework
that I'm looking for everybody
to come away with this is to
dream and imagine and project
how big of a deal voice is going to be.
For example, when I was in Seattle
there's a start-up working on
the number one paying point,
like literally VaynerMedia,
VaynerX could go out of business
because of the following thing.
It takes us 17 minutes, in
the beginning of a meeting,
to get our fucking PowerPoint
up on the fucking screen.
I mean there may not be a
shittier product on Earth
than Apple AirPlay right.
It just doesn't work.
And we keep thinking
it does but it doesn't.
They're working on the fact of an app
that you literally walk into
your office and just say
Alexa, put up the
PowerPoint and it's done.
Yeah.
I'm so pumped.
Time.
Time will always win.
Besides health, time
is the thing we value.
Money comes behind that.
If you do not understand that
you will underestimate this space.
What audio is about to do to
our society is create time.
The reason podcasts have
exploded in the last half decade
is because with technology we
can passively listen to them
and do something else.
The reason my podcast
viewership is stabilizing,
excuse me my video blog is stabilizing
but my podcast is growing,
is so much of my fan-base,
over time, migrates
after a couple of months,
once they get the visuals down
and they go to the audio
because they can listen to it
in any way, any time.
Next year BMW, Lexus, all
integrating into your car
these devices.
It's so funny.
The great fear of my life, as a parent,
was like shit, texting and
driving is scary, right.
We demonize drinking and driving.
Texting and driving is just like,
unfortunately it's killed an
enormous amount of people.
The fact that the age that my kids are
are never gonna get to that world
because we're not gonna text and drive.
Because in the next seven
years, five years, 10 years,
we're just gonna talk and drive.
Like you're just not gonna need it.
It's just not gonna happen.
It's remarkable how fast.
I talk a lot about okay, now
that we have the foundation
of this technology, the speed
and how these things turn
is gonna be remarkable.
It just is.
And so I really really really hope
the biggest thing you get
out of this conference,
and you can even tell by my demeanor.
It's interesting, I'm even
just like auditing myself
right now.
The hyperbole and the showmanship
and the excitement that
I tend to bring to stage
is muted this morning because I'm focused.
I'm like fuck man.
I'm kind of in the mindset
of like motherfuckers,
do you understand what's happening here.
(audience laughing)
And like the thing that
I love about technology
is so many of you regret missing out on
fuck, I jumped on Instagram late
or I wish I was on Twitter or
I screwed up, I should've
started a podcast.
Or goddammit I wish I
had an E-commerce site.
What's amazing about this game is that
if you win the next thing you make up for
all the losses of the past.
It's true.
All the regrets you may
have of the last 20 years,
of not moving fast enough, or
not establishing your agency
in that category or whatever it may be,
literally become irrelevant
if you can nail this.
But please understand one thing.
Not only has foresight
and intuition driven me
but the biggest thing that has driven me
over the last 25 years
absolutely is practicality.
I am not ideological about voice.
I would be thrilled to post
this keynote in seven years
on whatever we're consuming
with the headline of
remember when I totally fucked that up.
I have no emotion to this space.
What that means is there's
a lot of people here
that are gonna wanna build
their first skill on Google
and Amazon after the end of the day
and I want you to be very thoughtful about
where your business is right now.
If you're a Fortune 500
company that makes sense to me
because you can afford it and
you need to bring that DNA
into your company yesterday
so that the executives
don't go out and waste money
on just random shit
over the next two years.
And so the education and
the building is established.
But if you're a start-up or
a one woman show in here,
if that's taking time and
money out of other things
please recognize the size of the audience
is still very early.
Yes there's a lot of
devices in the marketplace
but most people are
just listening to music.
Right.
So the thing that I please implore you is
I jumped in heavy in social in 2005, 2006,
but it wasn't driving the
retail sales for Wine Library.
I wasn't putting out a
tweet and selling 100 cases
on winelibrary.com.
They were other things still doing that.
I knew, by 2010, '11, '12,
that this would have an impact
on my business and so
I was fully committed,
because I was running the
marathon of a culture's change.
Not trying to get the gold
rush of the first mover.
I am very fearful, very fearful,
that people leave this
state today and go home
and get really unpractical
and think this is some sort of
like gold rush or drilling
oil and it's gonna be eureka.
I do not expect a single
person here to have a skill
that they make that changes everything
within this first year
because I just don't see
the consumer behavior
mapping to that just yet.
But I will say this.
It just takes one killer app.
There's somebody right
now fishing up an idea
to build on top of one of these devices.
And guys don't get it twisted.
These devices and the technology is this.
When this came out people
grossly underestimated.
Even when they were hyped about apps
I don't think they fully
understood that the apps
that were built on this were
gonna be worth the money
and impact the world the way they did.
Waze.
Spotify.
Guys, WhatsApp is an app.
It's called WhatsApp.
It sold for $19 billion.
It's foundational to what Facebook does.
Snapchat.
These are publicly traded companies, Uber.
They're apps.
Please understand that
the devices are gonna have
apps on top of them.
That's going to be the game changer.
That's the marketplace
that Amazon, Google, Apple
and everybody else is gonna try to build.
That is the thing that
you're gonna try to build
to change the trajectory of your career.
Or, for a lot of you, that is
gonna be the things you market
on top of to build awareness
or to create conversion
for what you're up to.
And so if you think about it
think about listening to a podcast, right.
How many people here are
actively listening to podcasts?
Great.
As you know a lot of podcasts
are trying to monetize
and they do ads and live reads.
There's gonna be a very different thing
when you're consuming an
app or skill on a device
where there's an ad and your
ability to just say buy this
then creates a transaction.
How many people here have
had something show up
to their house from Amazon
because their under 12 year
old bought it on Alexa?
(audience laughing)
Somebody sent me an email
the other day and was like
dude I love for this VoiceCon
and good luck at VoiceCon,
I love voice, but motherfucker I had a
40 foot blow-up castle
show up to my house today.
(audience laughing)
Can you tell them to
get their shit together?
It's very likely that
this is the technology
that's gonna have the
biggest impact on your life.
So I applaud you for being here.
I really do.
Because what you're doing
is what I did in 2007
when I flew to London.
You see it, you intuitively understand it.
I think the line up that
you're gonna see today
is gonna get deep into the data.
You can bring out your
pads and take notes.
What I want you to do and
now I'll go into the details
and thrill to go back into the dirt
and get out of the clouds right now.
I'm about to do Q&A so,
where's the runners.
Got it, great.
Okay awesome, so please raise your hand
when you have a question
as soon as I wrap up here.
But please understand this.
Underestimating this
movement comes in two forms.
One, you're gonna have regret.
You're just gonna wake up in
20 years and be like fuck.
I went to VoiceCon and I
still didn't do shit about it.
Or it's gonna come in the
form of massive disruption
to the things that are
working for you now.
If your business is built on top of search
or what search is doing for you
you're about to get very
vulnerable over the next decade.
And so I highly recommend you
take this shift very serious
and start learning and start tasting
and to give you an insight to
what clearly worked in 2005
to 2008 for many people,
this is about tasting it.
This is about, if you believe in this,
you need to have a device
in every room in your home.
If you believe in this you
need to hire a developer
or rent a developer or even figure out
how to develop yourself and
create a very basic skill or app
calling on top of these devices.
Download other people's skills.
Get used to it so you can taste it.
You'll be brushing your teeth
listening to your device
and realize, wait a minute,
what that person just did
for jumping rope I can do
for my SaaS internet company.
You have to taste, in these early days,
because it's no different
than when you discover
a new land, right.
Like when people settle new worlds,
they get off the fucking
boat back in the day
and they see a bush with some fruit on it
that they've never seen before
and the head person goes
you go eat it.
(audience laughing)
And it's either a fucking raspberry
and it's delicious for the rest
of time or the fucker dies.
But you gotta taste it.
And so either you're gonna
fucking build a raspberry
or you're gonna fucking die.
But it's better than not trying at all.
So thank you for being here.
I hope you have a wonderful
day and I'm fired up.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Q&A, who's got a question?
Great, take it away runners.
Okay right here.
- First one, all right.
- Stand up.
Very tall man.
- So.
Yeah.
So obviously you're talking about
a lot of the consumer market, right.
- Yes.
- Because it's easy
to just say buy me this and that and that.
What do you see in other businesses,
let's say--
- Like B2B?
- [Man] Yeah B2B services.
Whatever there is.
Yeah.
- Well let's talk about
VaynerMedia's ambition.
We sent a dot to all of
our clients last year
where we recorded 180 employees' voices,
molded them together and
created VaynerMedia's voice
and every day our ambition is
to give them a marketing tip
which, as you can imagine, if you're a CMO
or a senior executive,
we know that they're not doing it yet,
we may have one or two clients doing it.
But we're getting our patterns right.
In three years, if you're
a service provider, right,
the fact that if you can penetrate,
and I think B2B is always
best because you know the 200
or 800 but you don't need
consumer success of millions.
If you could have your 800
biggest potential clients
or most important clients hear
your company every morning
for a minute with a
tip about the industry.
Not you being QVC, you being BBC.
Do you understand, you
have to bring them value.
Did you know or have you seen this trend?
Not in your self-interest.
Not like VaynerMedia
only pushing social media
and the person feels it's propaganda.
No it's bringing them value.
Do you understand what's
happening at retail
or have you seen this trend
or this stock price is up
and this is how it's
affecting your business.
Or this competitor's private
equity firm just sold.
Giving them value.
Guys it's always value.
It's always been about value.
The far majority of you like me
because I'm giving you value
with nothing in expectation of return.
It's not super complicated.
The one who brings more
value has the leverage.
So I think B2B's incredibly interesting.
- [Man] I just thought about
we have an IT service
company so, for example,
if in the morning I knew that
there is some stupid vendors
out there fucking servers
up and I tell them
be careful about this and.
- Always.
Value comes and it's also a
surprise and delight, right.
Let's just play this out.
You're giving them value of information,
value of information and
then randomly you throw them
a curve ball on Tuesday
April 13th that's like
hey and today we're giving
one month extra free service
or free this or a free ticket to VoiceCon.
Just to keep them interested right.
Creative.
One of the things I'm most excited about
in the advertising world
is that there's a lot of
copywriters right now
who write copy for videos
but she or he is not unbelievably
passionate about that.
Yet she doesn't even
realize she's two years away
for writing copy for long form skills
where we go down a path and
spend six hours playing Zelda
only through voice.
And what technology always does
is it brings us back, right.
Us knowing everything about each other
and us PR'ing to each
other on social media
is just back to the way we
used to do it in the village.
We knew everything about everybody.
We grew up, let me rephrase,
we, in the 20's, 30's and 40's
in this country and all over the world
heavily interacted with voice.
Soap operas started as radio shows.
I don't think people realize
that gaming is gonna be done
through voice 'cause you're
gonna be able to play.
You know how imaginative that's gonna be.
You know what happens when
you eliminate the visual?
Some of you remembered playing like that.
I did all kinds of imagination
gaming, just outside,
playing warriors and just doing dumb shit.
You're gonna be able to do that now so,
the reason I'm bringing it
up is we have to be creative.
We have to establish those cadence.
- [Man] Hey Gary, it's Jim
Meskimen the impressionist
we met in L.A.
- I remember,
how are you man?
- Such a big fan,
I'm here with my wife.
You've got a--
- What's your YouTube
cause I think people
really need to go see this
'cause
- I think so too.
- your shit's really good.
- Go ahead,
throw the right hook.
- It's Jim Meskimen
or if you look at Jimpressions
'cause I do celebrity voices
different things.
- Really interesting man.
- [Jim] Anyway that's not why
I'm here, not why I'm here.
But Gary you've got a great
mom, I've got a great mom.
My question, to phrase this as a question,
I know you were so busy, you
were such an entrepreneur
and such a busy kid, did
you ever watch Happy Days.
- Oh sure.
- Okay.
Well my mom is Marion Ross of
Happy Days who played Mrs C.
She has a book, she made a
special inscription just for you.
And I want you to read it 'cause
it'll make everybody laugh.
Can I bring it to you?
- You can bring it to me.
Fucking loved Happy Days.
I'm super pumped right now.
That's amazing man.
To Gary V.
I'm 80 fucking nine and
I'm still crushing it.
That's amazing.
Good thank you so much, that's amazing.
(audience applauding)
Amazing.
Next.
That's amazing, thank you brother.
Yep, stand up.
- [Man] Yeah how you doing Gary.
- Very good.
- We met at a
wine tasting event
in Jersey.
- I remember.
- [Man] Well one of the things I think
a lot of businesses are
gonna be worrying about
is about security.
- Yep.
- [Man] Convenience versus security.
- So the question is how
do we convince a business
to be more flexible and to relax on their
security policy or maybe
adjust their security policy
in order to look into voice.
- My point of view on this
is the word convince
scares the shit out of me.
I've spent my whole
career talking about stuff
that most people don't believe
at the time that I start talking about it
and I have found, through
the last 25 years,
that I'm way better off just
continuing to talk about it
and not convincing people but
letting the market force them
into my world.
You would be way better off,
if you decide to do something here,
to go to everybody and
focus on the three people
of 418 that do it with you
and do it amazing for them
than to sit there and
try to convince people
that are never gonna go there.
Convincing the inconvincible
is just a terrible strategy
that I see so many people
spending their time with.
I mean I sometimes go into a pitch
and I'm fundamentally checked out
within the first 10 minutes.
I'm like this is over.
We're here to check a box that they wanted
somebody innovative to
be here, they're out.
And what's crazy is I'm
not mad, it's business.
I signed up for this.
I just am not emotional
about convincing people.
I am thrilled to just stay
alive until it happens
and then look at them and
say fucking told you dick.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
Questions.
- [Man] I have a company.
I manufacture carbon composite
parts and metal parts.
- Okay.
- A lot of the parts
are confidential.
- Okay.
- [Man] How could I put that in voice
or even on just regular social media?
- Well you can't, it's confidential.
- [Man] Well I get it.
But how could I advertise my company,
I don't know.
- How do you build awareness
to get more business?
- Correct, correct.
- Who are you trying to get?
- [Man] Right now we're
doing some stuff with
aerospace companies and basically
more people that are doing
carbon composite parts
and that's pretty much it
- So what I would tell you is that
you probably need to
make videos, white papers
and long form written posts on LinkedIn
that are titled directly
for your industry.
- [Man] Okay.
- You know what I mean,
like six things that people
in this space don't know.
You need to build up thought leadership.
I vlog my day every day.
Vayner produces content scale,
I produce even more
content but I have clients
and we can't share all that
confidential stuff and so
we navigate around it.
I don't dwell on what I can't show.
Listen, for a lot of the
way I talk about stuff
I'm desperate to show
you how much of this shit
is actually working for
companies but I can't, right.
So I don't dwell on that
I just focus on creating
thought leadership which creates
gateways to opportunities.
You need to be putting
out written word, audio
and video pieces of content,
most likely in a LinkedIn
environment, in my opinion.
Especially 'cause post Cambridge
Analytica you can't target
based on employees of
which a lot of you know
I pontificated about
for years and it worked
and now it's gone and so I told you.
So I would do that.
- [Man] Thank you.
- But when you make the
content remember I said it.
Don't make it about you.
Everybody goes on LinkedIn,
or I've watched people take
my advice and they go on
and they basically write a press release.
You have to make pretend
you're not the retailer
or the company.
You have to make pretend
you're the media company.
So for example is there a B2B magazine
that the targets that
you're trying to reach
have in their industry.
You need to think like them
because you have to put out
articles that are valuable
for that decision maker.
Maybe even outside of your own service.
We don't do shopper
marketing at Vayner heavily
but I may write up shopper
marketing thought piece
leadership thing which is like
shopper marketing's bullshit,
it's just another way to say trade.
And that may bring awareness
to me and my company
which then may lead to them
using our E-commerce services.
Got it.
If you don't bring value
to them you've lost
and when you guys all
think about the skill
you should hear the first thousand skills
that have been pitched to me.
They're fucking garbage.
I've talked to big companies
and they're like Gary,
we'll make a skill about
the history of our company.
I'm like nobody about nobody gives a fuck
about the history of your company.
You care about the
history of your company.
Nobody gives a shit that
Uncle Thompson fucking started
the airline in 1912.
They care about is there
traffic to the airport
and did you stop them from wasting time.
Always think about them.
It's why I push empathy so much.
Once you deploy it and once
it becomes your strategy
you win.
You become actually consumer-centric.
Everybody talks about giving
a fuck about the customer.
Nobody shows me in their
actions that truth.
You care about your bottom
line financially and it shows.
So don't make the same
mistake you've made in digital
on voice.
That will be your breakthrough.
Questions.
- [Man] Erfi from Toronto.
Just contact--
- Good to see you.
- Angel VC stuff.
- I remember.
- [Man] So yes what do you
think the Angels and VC's
don't necessarily understand
about the voice phase
or what's to come.
- It's funny.
I think if you have a consumer-centric VC
who got to live through app culture
she and he are gonna be very smart.
'Cause the pattern's very obvious.
I don't know what they don't or do know.
I think that the biggest issue
probably for a lot of people
is that as we try to
figure out the UI and UX
of how voice works, I
think we're gonna bet on
a lot of founders who have theories
but we don't know that they
have the practitioner skillset
to navigate through this world.
So there'll be some guessing going on.
But the truth is I'm not sure.
I think, to be very frank,
and we've talked about this
in person, the VC game's
kind of interesting, right.
If you're a VC it's in your
vested interest right now,
if you believe in this space,
to go invest in 31 companies,
push them all real hard
to become the Facebook,
knowing that 30 of 'em are gonna die
because you're pushing them too hard
and you just need one
of 'em to get through
to pay back your entire fund.
That's VC.
Yes.
- [Woman] Good morning Gary.
- Hey.
- I'm Doctor Joella.
- How are you?
- [Jo] Good, I'm really
excited to be here.
- Thank you.
- Really excited
to talk to you and really excited
to be with everybody here.
- Thank you.
- [Jo] I am an injury
prevention specialist
in a sports chiropractor
and I'm gonna go from
treating patients to going online.
So I wanted to know how you
would imagine Alexa skill
for injury prevention.
- The question is do you
feel that you can articulate,
and this is a question for all of you
and so I appreciate the question doctor
'cause I think it's
gonna help a lot of you.
Do you feel that you
can transfer knowledge
that then helps the other
person on the other end
through voice?
My belief is what you're doing
is probably for some people
that have a good sense of, like,
I've been working out with
trainers every day for four years
and I still call every one of my muscles
the wrong fucking thing.
- Right.
- But they just keep laughing at me.
I just can't fucking grasp
it, I have no idea why.
But I would say this.
What gets really powerful
is being able to collect
information and where AI goes, right.
So if you think about your business.
If you upfront with your skill,
tell people hey, I'm gonna
be recording your answers
to help you in the future which,
no matter how much people
are scared about privacy,
they'll do in certain.
Certain things you're more
private about than others.
So the way the skill gets really crazy
is the collective AI and
brain power of it over time.
So hopefully hundreds then thousands
then tens of thousands of
people inputting information,
it itself gets smarter and
starts giving better advice
'cause it sees pattern
recognition of people answering
the same way based on
whatever the fuck, you know.
- Right.
- And so
I think what your ambition is is to build
the most seamless skill
for me to talk to it
in natural language and guide me through
whatever you're trying to guide me through
to fix or prevent my injuries.
- [Jo] So let me give you an example.
- Please.
- [Jo] Your head weighs,
on average, 13 pounds.
So if you draw it back over your shoulders
where your ear is in
alignment with your shoulders
you've taken off that pressure.
If you just--
- Yeah but then
how do I look at my phone.
- That's right!
That's right.
I did the angle on you.
- Yes.
- You're at 45 degrees.
That's 50 pounds of pressure
on your neck and shoulders
on those muscles and joints.
If you would just crane that head back
over your ear and shoulder
you would take that pressure off
and you wouldn't age those joints as fast
and that takes you moments.
And if you change you will
change for so many people
in the world.
That's the kind of information
I wanna give people.
- So on that note.
For me, first of all that's
very exciting news Doctor.
- [Jo] I'm so excited!
And I'm excited for you!
- I know myself super well
so I think I'm gonna hire
somebody to follow me
around 24 hours a day
and just make sure that my
head shoulder ratio is perfect.
- [Jo] There's a really easy
trick because what happens,
what you do is you bring
your phone down here.
If you would just bring
your arms into your body
and draw your phone up.
Raise your head up.
- Doc I wish Jordan was here
right now.
He's really been pushing me.
He really, to his credit.
- [Jo] I'm happy to talk to him.
- I'm happy to hook you
guys up.
- joellacastillo@mac.com.
- I love it!
I appreciate it.
So listen, here's what I would say.
You've got a really great thing
and we didn't touch on this and again
I'm trying to leave the details
for the rest of the speakers.
Briefings.
A skill is AI, you navigate,
you can talk back and forth.
A briefing is a piece of information.
Everybody here can start
their briefing very quickly.
If you have 365 thoughts
you've got a briefing
that can be there every day.
What you just did was more of a tip.
A did you know.
Your ability to create a briefing,
which would cost you nothing,
in comparison to a skill
where you need a developer.
A briefing, recording it, uploading it.
You having a tip of
the day for prevention,
that is absolutely something
that you can get started on
right away and little tidbits like that,
do you have 365 tidbits?
- [Jo] Yes.
- Great.
Then you should start a briefing tomorrow.
- [Jo] Okay.
- Awesome, thank you doc.
- [Jo] Thank you.
- Next.
- [Jo] And everybody needs
to raise their head up.
- Oh God she's so right.
50 fucking pounds.
And I don't think my head's 13,
I think my head's like 12.
So I'm 46, go ahead.
- [Man] Hey Gary, first thanks
for being our CMO for free.
Appreciate that.
- My pleasure.
- [Man] Nice to get back
a little bit of your--
- Thanks.
- [Man] My son, when
he was in fourth grade,
he had his self-confidence
wrecked by a teacher
who nicknamed him Tweedledum.
- Right.
I wanna fucking punch that
teacher in the fucking face.
- [Man] My wife got close.
- [Gary] Can you give
me the teacher's name?
- What's that?
- Being serious.
Like fuck that teacher.
I wanna make a post and be like
this teacher's a piece of shit.
- [Man] Well here's the good part.
- Can we do that?
- His fifth grade teacher,
his fifth grade teacher saved him.
Turned him around.
- Love it.
- But in the same year that
his fifth grade teacher
became a good friend
of mine he lost his son
that same year.
- The fifth grade teacher?
- Yeah yeah.
So he was digging deep in the same year.
I don't know how he did it.
So now a few years later
he's obviously still hurting
in a big way.
Now this guy, he has it
in him to be an amazing,
unbelievable, off the charts podcaster.
He has the love that he's got
and the ability to communicate it.
I saw him do it with my son,
I've seen him do it with other kids.
I'm trying to convince him
- To do it.
- but I don't wanna push.
Yeah, 'cause I'm afraid to--
- Where do you live?
- North Carolina.
- [Gary] Do you think you can get him
up into my office for 30 minutes?
- Yeah probably, yeah.
- Let's do it.
- [Man] Okay, all right.
- I'll convince him.
- All right.
All right thank you.
- Hopefully that happens
and please email me
gary@vaynermedia, say I'm the guy
with the teacher and the
podcast, we'll set that up.
If you can do it.
If he doesn't wanna do
that or balks at that
or you can't get it done,
this is kind of how.
And I've gotta wrap up
and thank you for being here
everyone, one last time.
This is how I think about it
and I think you're seeing it
through my actions right now
in my content.
And it's no different than convincing.
The way you get it done is by
never giving up telling him
he should do it.
Literally the second
before I got on stage here,
you can go to my Instagram right now.
Actually that'll be fun, I'm
not gonna say what it is.
Go to my Instagram right now
and see what my latest post is.
It's exactly what I think you
need to do with this teacher
because it's the only move we've got.
Cool.
- Yeah.
- Cool, thank you everyone.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Have a great day, thank you.
Thank you.
(inspiring music)